[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELIZABETH SWEENY: I'm going to
kind of set the stage for us,
and I will say, whether
our users are enterprise
clients or individual
consumers, we really want them
to have a great experience.
It's kind of the core of
what we're searching for.
And I actually had a really
interesting experience
this past week that I
think kind of sums up
why this is an important
experience for your users,
and I'd like to
recount that with you.
So if I'm moving a little
slowly on stage today,
it's because I actually had
an emergency abdominal surgery
just a few days ago.
But the great part
is I didn't have
to change my slides at all.
I just have a way better story
to go with them, so worth it.
So exactly a week ago,
almost to the hour,
I started having abdominal
pain, and I was like, huh, OK,
I want to look up
what's going on.
Why does this hurt?
And I want to know
treatment options.
So I type into search,
"abdominal pain that
could kill horses," and I
see a few different site
options pop up.
I click on one of the
first ones, and I get this.
This did not delight me.
I was very frustrated with this
outcome at that point in time.
And so I pop out of this
site, because I'm like, this,
I can't handle right now.
I return to the search results,
and I click another option.
I get something even worse.
Is it loading?
Is it happening?
There's no feedback, right?
And I'm stuck just
really wanting
to know why I feel like
I'm going to explode,
and I'm not getting
any information.
So it finally starts to
load, thank goodness.
But the content that
is rendered on the page
isn't the content that I want.
What was happening was something
that's normally further
down on the page, the way that
the code was being shipped,
was being rendered first.
And so I was actually
being shown risk factors
for abdominal issues instead
of treatment options.
So I want to know if I need
to go to the emergency room
to not die, and
instead, I'm being
told that I'm most
likely, given my symptoms,
a 60-year-old male who lives
in a retirement community.
Not good.
But finally, the
right content loaded,
and it basically
told me that, yes,
I do need to seek medical care.
And I go to click on the link.
It doesn't respond.
The site's not interactive yet.
The main thread is too
busy, and so I'm stuck.
So this whole
experience, just no.
You never want to give
this for your users.
This is not what they want.
This is the opposite of what
you need them to experience,
and users notice it,
and they hate it.
But that's a problem that's
way too common on the web.
And there are a lot of things
that can torpedo your ability
to avoid this, and
so that's what I want
to talk to you about today.
I want to talk about the
impetus behind building
a really high quality experience
and the core principles that
define that quality and
how you can effectively
measure, optimize, and
monitor those core principles.
So we know how
frustrating it is to have
a bad experience on the web,
as my experience just showed.
But how universal
is this reality?
Let's put it in the context
of stress response factors.
So this is actually a consumer
study done by Ericsson,
and they asked consumers
to rank stress factors.
Waiting in line at
a retail store--
we know that we hate this,
and we want our latte,
and we want it now.
OK, great.
Even worse-- watching
a melodramatic TV show.
And I stole this joke, but
it's too good to pass up--
Netflix and not chill.
Then you can be standing at
the edge of a virtual cliff
and watching a horror
movie-- these are all
stressful experiences.
But what's worse than "Cujo"?
Mobile delays on a site.
Right?
It's the worst.
Well, no, the only
thing that's worse
is solving a math problem.
We don't want to make
our users do that either,
but that I think we all
understood intuitively.
So I'm standing
here, because I want
to make sure that all
stakeholders fundamentally
understand the importance
of developers spending time
on investing in these core
principles of quality.
This is not an exercise of
espousing best practices just
for the sake of it.
It is about your bottom line.
So just to give some
more context for that
through an example, Pinterest
revamped their mobile web
experience to focus
on performance
and saw tremendous results.
Their mobile website is
now their top platform
for sign-ups, and similarly,
after implementing
and enforcing a really
aggressive but reasonable
performance budget,
Tinder was able to see
more swipes on the web now than
they do on their mobile app.
So over and over again,
we see the same pattern.
Those who know how to design and
implement a really high quality
experience on the web see
increased satisfaction,
more time spent on pages, and
ultimately, higher revenue.
So we see that sweet spot
is around two seconds
with conversion rates dropping
with every millisecond
of slowdown after that.
So it's important
to have an accurate
measurement as well, which
we'll talk about a bit later.
Performance sites
are profitable sites.
That's the moral of the story.
But where do you start?
There's a lot going on.
You start with a business
goal, effectively,
because that's what
you're looking for.
You don't want to just have a
great FCP for the sake of FCP,
as cool as that is.
You want to make
sure that you're
addressing core business goals.
So what are those
core principles that
allow you to accomplish that?
The example I gave earlier is
actually a really complicated
one, because my trying
to actually engage
with web content that
wasn't loading properly
caused a slew of
user pain points.
It wasn't just a single problem.
It wasn't just that it
wasn't loading quickly.
It was that it
was loading wrong.
And like I said, it's
difficult to define quality,
so let's take a stab at it.
There's a lot of ways
to break it down,
but there are a
few core principles
that are fairly
canonical and don't often
shift, so even in the
face of strong new fads.
So I'd like to go over
those underlying principles,
the first step
being performance.
Speed and the user
perception of speed
is going to be at the
core of our metrics
and tooling discussion
in a few minutes.
But it's one of the
most critical points
that you're going
to want to focus on.
But there's also things
like accessibility,
and we want your site to be
accessible for everybody.
Why would you want to miss
out on potential consumers?
This means that the site's
content and functionality
can be operated by
literally anyone.
It's really altogether
too easy to assume
that people engage with content
the same way that we do.
And while we tend to center
the discussion of accessibility
on people with
physical impairments,
often, we can all
relate to experiences
of using an interface in a way
that isn't particularly helpful
and that isn't accessible
for other reasons.
So for instance, if you
are using a desktop site
on a mobile phone, I
feel like I'm can just
stop with the examples
there, and everybody
can feel the pain, or
seeing the message,
this content is not
available in your area, which
in India, could
not watch anything,
or been unable to find a
familiar menu item on a tablet.
All these things are
accessibility issues as well.
For discoverability, everything
else is kind of a moot point
if people don't find you.
So there are a lot
of things that you
can do to help in terms of
how you actually implement
your site, such as
giving your site a really
strong URL structure.
I mean the more structure
you give, the more
indexable you're going to be.
Making your site responsive
and that it's easily consumable
on all devices, using
rel canonical and rel
alternative for separate
desktop and mobile sites--
there are a slew of
other tips and tricks
to make your site
more discoverable.
But at the end of
the day, we want--
the web is all about
driving people to you.
That's one of the things we're
best that, so to leverage it
to the full extent of
its ability, smart move.
Security-- I mean from
authenticating your users,
maintaining sessions with
them, encrypted communications,
security is kind of a
universally accepted core
quality.
And it encompasses
so many subtopics,
but at the end of the
day, if you think about it
from the perspective
of the end user,
if they're not comfortable
interfacing with you
and giving you any sort
of tangible insight
into their needs, you're
both going to hurt.
Smoothness-- I really,
really like coffee.
And I love coffee.
But smoothness on
a web page means
that things aren't
janky or moving around
everywhere just kind
of in a weird way.
It means that animations
aren't stuttering or unnatural,
and it also means that
everything just feels seamless.
And we all know what that
feels like, and it feels good.
So fundamentally, this comes
down to a few core concepts--
choosing the right
things to animate
and being aware of the
performance trade-offs,
because sometimes they can
be unexpectedly draconian.
So watching out for that is key.
Using animations to
support interactions
and not unnecessarily
hindering the page
or the user's interactions--
so we all remember Clippy.
Like, we-- yeah.
Enough said.
And avoid animating
expensive properties.
Basically, stick to transforms
and opacity changes.
If all else fails, those
are your guiding lights.
So all of these core
principles amount
to being able to answer this
question with a resounding
"heck yes," because you
want to let your users,
and delighting your users means
performant, accessible, secure,
discoverable, and smooth sites.
And it's interesting to
consider the core principles
and how they've evolved in the
context of both native and web
applications.
Many of the web
applications that we've
seen develop over
the past few years
have been to enable the
same richness of experience
that people have
become traditionally
accustomed to in native apps.
And many of the web
technologies that Thomas
is going to talk
about that we've
seen develop over the past
few years, like I said,
are to do this.
And the strength of the web
has been primarily in reach,
but these web technologies have
been changing that equation.
So yeah, I already
said this slide.
I am just like--
yeah.
I'm going to keep going.
That's one of the
reasons why PWAs
came about is to really
make that rich experience
achievable in a much more
simple, straightforward way.
So progressive web apps
allow your web experience
to be fast because of
caching and prefetching,
integrated, because it gives
you that prime real estate
on the home screen.
It's reliable with network
fluctuations because of service
workers and offline
capabilities,
and then engagement
with push notifications.
So it feels very
intuitive for the user
to engage with it as they
would in a native application.
And ultimately, the slew of
technologies that underpin PWAs
allow for easier achievement of
quality, as we've talked about.
So as we saw before, Pinterest
updated their web experience
and saw tremendous results.
But this was with a PWA,
just to kind of fall
back on that context.
And they ultimately were
looking and analyzed usage
for unauthenticated
mobile web users,
and they realized
that their old, kind
of out-of-date experience only
managed to convert 1% of users
into sign-ups, logins,
or native app installs.
And the opportunity to improve
this conversion was huge.
So things like
boosting engagement
with push notifications
was a big deal for them.
And as a result, they
see time spent up 40%,
and core engagement is up 60%.
So what's the takeaway?
The core principles
foundationally
underlie the acquisition,
engagement, conversion,
and retention of your users.
That's why they're canonical.
Performance, accessibility,
security, discoverability,
and smoothness--
they all directly impact
the business's ability
to execute against its
most rudimentary goals.
So if these principles
are so important,
then why do we regress or
not really ever kind of
get started with them?
Before we get into some of
the more nitty-gritty of how
we measure these core
principles quantitatively,
I wanted to take a look at
some of the components that
are less technical that cause
challenges to actually execute
against this high
quality experience.
And one of the challenges is
having all the stakeholders
onboard.
You want to have the
organization fully bought
in to the fact that we have a
stake in these core principles
and that it has a direct
effect on your bottom line.
If there's any disjoint in
that, it causes problems.
So let's take this
as an example.
I know it's a busy
slide, and I apologize.
But in the red org structure,
performance and other core
implementations are
siloed from marketing
and other critical
business teams
with no visibility,
shared accountability.
It's kind of difficult.
But even when it's shared,
stakeholders don't often
know who shares the code.
So that makes it difficult.
Things are better
in the green org
structure, where the core
principles of quality
are well-defined.
They're owned by management,
and they're enforced throughout.
It needs to be one
of the first things
that a team considers
when they're
designing something
new, not something to be
tacked on later.
I think most people
in the audience
probably understand that
pain a little too acutely,
because there is nothing
more painful than having
to layer on security
or performance
onto a fundamentally
insecure non-performant site.
It is painful.
But this can be seen in
how organizations often
approach the designing
of their web apps.
Performance is an
afterthought, and a lot
of the core principles
come to light
in the heat of an emergency,
like customers are complaining.
We're losing money.
Panic ensues.
And then you get Band-Aid
fixes, and as soon
as the fire tamps down, those
things go down in the priority.
And that's not sustainable.
But like I said, at
the end of the day,
these core principles are
about solving business problems
and understanding that
the conversation--
we need to increase conversions,
and we need to lower our FCP--
are the same
conversation is something
that is so critical to get
both business stakeholders
and engineering really excited
about solving these problems.
Now it's time to get
to the good stuff.
So we can't improve
what we can't measure.
We need to know
what we're measuring
and how to measure it.
So let's start with a
brief history of things,
just to whet the appetite again
for why measuring precisely
has become so important.
So welcome to the
human attention span.
Even in 2000-- yeah,
that was nine years ago,
I realized, a few days
ago, which is terrifying.
The average human could
have barely waited
for the average page
in the Netherlands
to load- just
couldn't handle it.
You'd walk away.
Even a goldfish would
be too impatient to wait
for the average
EMEA site to load.
And then in 2013, we
got even more impatient,
and our attention decreased to
lower than that of a goldfish.
Humanity's great.
And now here's the
good and the bad news.
Online, you really
only have three seconds
before you lose people.
And I actually don't know
why that's good and bad news.
It's just kind of news that
needs to be accounted for.
So you have three
seconds, but there's
a lot to do in three
seconds, and it's always
a balancing act, and you're
going to have to prioritize.
The impact on user
experience is critical.
So you look at the fact that
the speed it takes a load a page
is the most important
factor for a user,
far and above how easy it
is to find what they want,
more important than the
simplicity of using the site,
and three times more
important than how
attractive the site looks.
So performance is important.
You're going to be really
bored of hearing me saying that
by the end of this.
But before we learn
where to measure,
what are we actually measuring?
Loading isn't a
single moment in time,
and there isn't one metric
that can fully capture it.
So this gets back
to my experience
that when a page loads,
it begs the question, what
is performance?
It's partly the speed of
initial load, to be sure,
but how do we actually
break that down?
And focusing on user
performance metrics
is a great way to get started.
A user perceives that
something is happening.
Am I receiving content?
That's-- is it happening?
And that's first paint and
first [INAUDIBLE] pain.
Is it useful?
Is what I'm receiving
visible and digestible?
That's first meaningful paint.
And then is it usable?
If I click on it,
will it respond?
That's time to interactive.
Taking one step
down, so FCP actually
measures the time
from navigation
to the time when a browser
first renders the first bit
of content onto the page.
So it's an important
milestone for the user,
because it provides feedback
that something's actually
happening and that
the page is loading.
The time to interactive metric
measures how long a page takes
to actually become
interactive, so it means
that interactive
defined by a page
has displayed useful content.
Event handlers are
registered, and the page
responds to user interactions
within 50 milliseconds.
So it's a difficult
metric to achieve,
and it's much later in
load, but it's important,
because you know
that rage clicking?
That's that.
And this is a great example of
a metric that's great in the lab
but doesn't work as
well in the field,
because people
actually have to--
did I swap that?
I don't know if I swapped that.
So yeah, time interactive,
great in the lab,
not so great in the field,
because in the field,
you need actually somebody
responding and pushing
on the screen to get that
input, whereas with TTI, it's
just simulated.
And we'll talk about the
differences between lab
and field in a minute.
But FID is where we're
talking about-- it measures
the time from when a user first
interacts, clicks, or taps,
and when the browser is
actually able to respond
to that interaction.
So in general,
input delay happens,
because the browser's
main thread is too busy,
and we're doing something
else, and it can't yet
respond to the user.
We all know that.
One common reason
that can happen
is the browser is busy
parsing a lot of JavaScript.
We know that depending
on how you bundle it,
it'll affect this
experience for the user.
And to dive one step deeper than
that, on the goldfish slide,
you lose people
at three seconds,
but they notice latency at
anything over 100 milliseconds.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
We perceive-- we
perceive that change,
and that measurement is
incredibly important.
So quick raise of hands.
Who prefers A?
Who prefers B?
Yeah.
Unfortunately, some sites
optimize content visibility
at the expense of interactivity.
So you have A. It's great.
It's loaded.
But you're clicking on it.
It's not doing anything,
whereas with B, you're
not seeing something, but as
soon as you see something,
you click, and it works.
Both kind of suck.
Right?
Like, eh, you want
some healthy balance.
To the best of your
ability, you're
trying to optimize for
both, and that's hard to do.
So why do we care about
all these metrics?
Because all of them represent
a different part of the user
experience, and as we said,
it's not a single metric.
It's really a
cohesive experience.
So you'll see--
I know we have a lot of
moving goal posts sometimes
with metrics, but
we're constantly
trying to find what is
actually representative
of what the user is experiencing
when something loads.
So there are two sides to
the measurement equation,
as I kind of alluded to earlier.
There's performance in
the lab, and there's
performance in the real world.
Now you can look at this
from the perspective
of both metrics, as well as
measurement of those metrics.
So lab measurement,
synthetic testing,
where you can test code quality.
The others field where
you're looking at real user
interactions and understanding
how they are actually
experiencing a site.
Some metrics are
available in both.
Some, one or the other.
Like I said, nearly everything
is available in the lab,
but FID is unique, because
you need that real user input.
And TTI and FID are
interactivity metrics,
so they're going to be sensitive
to the main thread activity.
It's good to kind of
get a sense of when
you're going to get that rage
clicking scenario going on.
So lab data is fantastic
for a lot of reasons.
It gives a sense of how
changes are likely to behave
in the real world.
You can catch problems
before making things go live.
They're helpful for
debugging performance issues,
reproducible.
It's great.
But the downsides
are that they're not
going to really capture
real world bottlenecks,
and they can't correlate
against real world KPIs.
So that's a downside.
So that's where
field data comes in,
and it complements
it beautifully.
Real world's
messy-- permutations
of devices, network
configurations,
cache conditions.
I mean, it's
impossible to simulate
all these things in the lab,
and you need those real signals.
So RUM helps--
Real User Measurement
actually helps
you understand what
matters most to real users,
their actual behavior,
and that might
be different than
your assumptions.
Best strategy?
Combine the two.
Having both lab
and field metrics
is a proxy for what your
users are experiencing
and how they're experiencing the
core principles of your site.
So we know we want
lab and field data.
Great.
Where do we get it?
So the primary three
metrics that we've
discussed kind of on
an ongoing basis today
are available in their
respective lab and field
environments.
Because FCP can be measured
both in the lab and field
with users, it is
available across the board
in tools like Lighthouse,
PageSpeed Insights, Chrome User
Experience Report, and actually
as a web perf API as well.
TTI is only
available in the lab,
so it can be accessed via
Lighthouse and PageSpeed
Insights, and FID requires the
real user input, as we said,
so you can go to CrUX for that.
My tip of the day, just
to make your life easier--
if you want to get a snapshot
of your site's lab and field
performance to benchmark
overall quality,
go run your page through
PageSpeed Insights.
So you can do this via a web
app at the URL shown here
or via the V5 API
that we launched
in November of last year.
At the top of the
PSI report, you'll
see a high level
performance score, which
is the same that you see
if you run Lighthouse,
and it's calculated based
on the lab metrics that
are measured and weighted.
Metrics that contribute
to this high level score
include things like FCP,
FMP, Speed Index, and TTI.
And you'll clearly see
in the field report--
in the PSI report, that
you've run both field and lab,
which is really
cool to have in one
place, and from their respective
sources, CrUX and Lighthouse.
So the two primary field metrics
are pulled out for the URL
that you run.
And so for each metric, you see
the percentage of page loads
that, in the real world,
were slow, average, or fast.
What a tool like
Lighthouse offers
you is that if you use it
via one of the surfaces
other than PSI, it
gives you a means
to measure more of
the core principles
aside from just performance.
So you can audit your site for
accessibility, best practices,
search engine optimization,
and which criteria
have been filled for PWA.
Lighthouse also allows
you to dive more deeply
into opportunities
for each category,
making improving the
quality of your site
really actionable and tangible.
So setting performance
budgets are a fantastic way
to keep from regressing as
well and can be one of the most
effective ways to
monitor, so we're
talking measuring,
optimizing, and monitoring.
This is where the
monitoring comes in.
Budgets can take on many forms,
but setting them and enforcing
them, even in the
context of the latest
and greatest new feature--
it's great to push
back on features
you don't want to implement,
by the way, pro tip--
it's going to help your
pocketbook big time.
So there are a
slew of tools that
are at your disposal
that can help
you gauge the
quality of your site,
ranging in level
of technicality.
And I encourage you to
enjoy playing with them,
both in the lab and field.
Your users and your bottom
line will thank you for it.
And with that, I pass it to
my amazing colleague, Thomas.
THOMAS NATTESTAD: Thank
you so much, Elizabeth.
Yeah, round of
applause for Elizabeth.
[APPLAUSE]
She literally dragged herself
out of the hospital bed
to be here in order
to give this talk,
and if that's not caring about
metrics, I don't know what is.
So for my part of the talk,
I want to share about some
of the new things
that we're building
in Chrome that
fundamentally expand
the set of experiences that are
possible to create on the web.
And in order to
showcase how impactful
some of these improvements and
technological changes can be,
I want to first take a step
way back and understand the web
as a platform and as
an application platform
compared to how Android,
iOS, and Windows are also
these application platforms.
And so to really
take a step back,
I'm going to step way back
to the first ever web page
published by Tim Berners Lee.
And as you can
see, this web page
is really just very slightly
formatted text, some of which
you could click on to get
to other pages of slightly
formatted text.
And that's all the web was.
Then a little something
called JavaScript came along,
which was famously created and
written in a 10-day hackathon.
And this 10-day hackathon
brought JavaScript
and brought interactivity to
the web for the first time ever.
Suddenly, you could
respond to user input,
do dynamic logic on
your page itself,
and even with this
very basic set
of interactivity
functionality, you
saw the first wave
of web applications.
In the past, things like Outlook
and other native applications
had been the only
way to do email,
and now suddenly, you
could just type Gmail.com,
and you were in an
email client, where
you could send and receive
and manage all your emails.
And there were, of course,
many other applications that
followed along, things
like MapQuest or eBay,
things that were highly
interactive and dynamic now
being able to be delivered
directly through the browser.
But why were these applications
actually moving to the web?
In the native world, you can
use any language you want,
not just JavaScript.
You have full
access to everything
that the computer can do.
You can do absolutely anything
to your heart's desire,
so why were applications
actually moving to the web?
Well, it turns
out that there are
three fundamental
properties that
make the web a really
unique platform.
The first of these, and
one that is unsurprising,
is linkability, the ability to
have a single string that then
maps to the web page itself, and
have that string be clickable
from any other page so that
you can find your application
really easily,
but also shareable
so that I can share
a simple string that
shares not only the
application itself, but also
a specific document
for that application
that can now be
instantly accessed.
The second property of the
web is its ephemerality.
And this Is a very fancy
word that basically
means that the user doesn't
have to worry about installing
the application, do they have
enough space on their machine,
and do they actually
trust the application.
The application or
website is delivered
through the browser
completely sandboxed,
and the user never has
to worry about clicking
a link the same way they
should be absolutely
terrified about
installing an EXE.
And lastly, the web is the
only truly universal platform,
meaning that your application
is accessible by anyone
on any device.
Today, the web obviously
runs on desktop, laptops,
and mobile phones,
but also on watches,
and I've seen the web
literally running on treadmills
and refrigerators.
And this means that you
can use your single code
base to power all
of your deployments,
even to reach your
fridge-based users.
So now, hopefully,
that we all have
a better shared understanding
of what the web is and some
of the properties that define
it, I want to share about some
of the new technologies
that we're building in
to Chrome that developers
can use to, again,
expand the set of
things that are actually
possible to do on the web.
And the first of these
that I want to talk about
is WebAssembly.
WebAssembly is a new
low level binary format,
which means that it's close to
the CPU virtual machine code
that your computer understands,
but with all of the safety
and sandboxing that you've
come to expect from the web.
WebAssembly, much like
Assembly, is compiled from other
languages like C++, meaning
that you probably shouldn't be
writing WebAssembly by hand,
unless that's your thing.
And because WebAssembly is
a low level binary format,
it offers better maximized
and reliable performance
than JavaScript can.
So let's dive in to some of
the advantages of WebAssembly
in detail.
As I mentioned, WebAssembly
is compiled ahead of time from
something like C++, and that
means that you can do a lot
of optimizations and performance
tuning before the code actually
hits the browser.
JavaScript, by contrast,
is sent as raw source code
to the browser, and
then the browser
has to optimize it
as it's actually
being executed on the page.
And this can cause
some of that choppiness
that you sometimes
get on web pages.
Critically, WebAssembly
also gives you
more access to your CPU.
We recently launched
WebAssembly Threads,
and WebAssembly Threads let
you use the multiple cores that
come on practically every
CPU to fully squeeze out
every ounce of performance.
And to showcase some of
these performance differences
and to actually hear some
of these differences,
I'm going to jump ahead
to the case studies
that I'll get to later, and show
off one specific example called
Soundation.
Soundation is a fantastic
web application.
They have a C++ code base, and
Soundation is a music editing
studio similar to GarageBand
that lets you easily mix
and match songs with
various effects.
They have a C++ application that
they compiled to WebAssembly,
and it works really fantastic.
But sometimes when you have
to render really complex songs
in real time, the performance
demands on that application
can be intense.
We actually partnered with
them to try and render
one of their difficult
to render songs,
and we tried to do this on
a single-threaded version
of their application.
And we're going to get to
hear what that sounds like.
Fair warning-- this is not going
to be a pleasant experience.
But if we have audio, which
it doesn't sound like we do--
[BROKEN MUSIC PLAYING]
Ah, there it is.
So I'm going to move past
that, because clearly,
we can all tell that is a
terrible experience, not
something you want your
users listening to.
But as soon as they turned
on WebAssembly Threads,
they were able to
render that same song--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--now sounding much more normal
and using far less of the CPU.
So that was just one performance
advantage of WebAssembly,
and letting you really
maximize everything
that you can get out of the CPU.
Another advantage of
WebAssembly is its portability.
Because you compile WebAssembly
from other languages like C++,
you can port not only
your own applications that
you've written in C++, but also
the wealth of open source C++
libraries and application that
exist out there in the world.
And because C++ specifically
is supported across practically
every platform, including
iOS and Android,
you can now use C++ as your
common language across all
of your different deployments,
even if you want that iOS
and Android native application.
Lastly, and potentially
most exciting
to many of the developers
out there in the audience,
is the promise of
more flexibility
when writing for the web.
In the past, JavaScript
was the only option
that you had for fully
browser-supported language,
and now with WebAssembly,
you get more choice.
The set of fully supported
languages today are C, C++,
and Rust, but there are
many other languages,
including Kotlin and .NET,
which are working on adding
experimental support
to WebAssembly,
and some of these have
actually already shipped that
experimental support.
The most exciting thing
about WebAssembly,
though, is that it is
fully launched in all four
major browsers, meaning
that you can truly
use WebAssembly to reach every
single one of your web users.
It's important to know, though,
at this point that WebAssembly
is explicitly not a
replacement for JavaScript.
Rather, WebAssembly is meant
to augment all of the things
that JavaScript isn't
really designed for.
JavaScript is a dynamic
language, useful for scripting.
If you want to do
simple interactivity,
JavaScript is and remains
the way to do that.
But if you want to really
maximize your performance,
really get that
reliability, WebAssembly
gives you that option.
If you want to get
started with WebAssembly,
the first thing to
check out is Emscripten.
Emscripten is a highly advanced
tool chain that not only helps
you compile your C++ into
the WebAssembly format,
but it also does a
lot of emulation.
For example, if your application
uses open GL rendering calls,
Emscripten will automatically
transfer those open GL calls
into web GL calls so
that you can really
easily wholesale port your
entire application using
the Emscripten tool chain.
OK, so that was
WebAssembly, and now I
want to switch tracks
and talk a little bit
about some of the
new capabilities
that we're adding to Chrome.
Again, going back to the
world's first ever web page,
we can see that you really
couldn't do anything.
Outside of the
lack of JavaScript,
there really wasn't
any additional access
or functionality that you
could get out of your web page.
Then the image tag came
along, and suddenly, you
could show images
on your web page.
And that was a huge deal
and a major development.
It was great.
But obviously, the
story didn't stop there.
And today, many
of you likely know
that you can access location
and even get a camera feed.
You can take your
website into full screen
mode, all of these
different capabilities
that you've all seen.
But the picture is actually
so much more complex
than most people imagine.
Today, on the web, you can
do so much more, things
like accessing USB devices,
sending push messages,
managing your credentials,
weaving files, syncing
in the background, detecting
your device position,
vibration.
All of these different things
are accessible through browser
standardized APIs.
But the story is
far from complete,
and I'm happy to say
that in 2019 and 2020,
Chrome is planning to
dramatically expand
the set of capabilities that
your browser can access.
These include things
like SMS verification,
the ability to see
the contacts that
are on a device, task
scheduling, and even
the ability to write back to
files that have been shared
with your website
so that you can
create a rich native-like
file editor or even an IDE.
I want to dive into a few of
these specific capabilities
in more detail.
The first of these is offline.
As you all know,
the web is great
when you have a secure, reliable
connection, as most of us
do on desktop machines,
but not so much on mobile.
The way that a traditional web
server works with a browser
is you go, and you
fetch your content,
you load it into the browser,
and yeah, you're done.
But when you have poor
connectivity or even
no connectivity, that's a
really negative experience,
and you end up seeing
what's called--
what we like to call the
offline-asaurus-rex or Offline
Dino.
And as much fun as this
game is-- which by the way,
hit space, if any of
you haven't before--
this isn't really the content
that users are looking for.
Luckily, though, in
the last few years,
we've been launching something
called Service Worker.
And what Service
Worker lets you do
is that once you've actually
fetched your web application,
you can intelligently
cache it, and then
detect that when the user tries
to come back to your website,
if they're on poor connectivity
or no connectivity,
you can serve that same web
page directly from the cache.
And then if the user eventually
enters a better connectivity
state, you can then
fetch the updated content
and serve that to your
users on return visits.
Another important capability
that we give you access to,
if you have a service
worker in your application,
is the ability to add your
website to the home screen.
And this is what we call PWAs.
And this is that ability to
render a button that says,
Install, and when
the user clicks it,
they'll say, yes, I want to
add this to my home screen.
And then you actually
get a standalone icon
on the user's device.
And when they
click that icon, it
opens up into a full screen
view with no URL bar at the top
whatsoever, and it
really feels and looks
like a native application.
Another important
capability is the ability
to send push messages.
This is something that iOS
and Android has had access to
since the beginning, but
it's also now something
that you have access
to through the browser
and have had access to
for the last few years.
It works exactly the same way
it does in iOS and Android.
And once the user
grants the permission
to be shown push
notifications, you
can send them directly
from your web application.
So these together kind of form
what we call Progressive Web
Applications, or PWAs.
And these are all
about delivering
that native look and feel
of an application using
all of the web-based
technologies that are also
so powerful and in the browser.
And we're at a place today,
where you can quite literally
create a PWA and a
native app experience
alongside each other,
completely undetectable
which one is the web experience.
And you're welcome to try
and guess which of these two
is the native and
which one is the PWA.
For those of you who guessed
that the one on the left
there is the PWA,
you were right,
but I'm willing to guess
that that was mostly based
on random luck, because
these two experiences really
are interchangeable and
completely indistinguishable.
I'm also happy to say that with
progressive web applications,
we have now completely
expanded to desktop.
It works exactly the
same way on desktop.
You can render an
Install button.
When the user
decides to install,
you can simply say
yes, and then you
get, again, that same
icon in the shelf,
as well as your own
standalone window,
fully integrated into the
operating system, feeling
exactly like a
native application.
We also launched recently
something called Trusted Web
Activities.
Trusted Web Activities, or
TWAs, let you take your PWA
and turn it into an
Android native APK
that you can list directly
in the Play Store.
TWAs, instead of
using web views,
use something called
Chrome Custom Tabs.
And this means that TWAs share
and sync storage with Chrome.
This means that if
a user is locked
into your site on Chrome,
and they then go and download
your TWA from the
Android Play Store,
they'll automatically be
logged in, and all of the data
will be synced,
enabling them to switch
between your
in-browser experience
and your app experience
completely seamlessly.
The resulting APK that you get
out on the other end for a TWA
is also incredibly tiny, smaller
than any native application
that you could have made.
And this has been
really impactful
for a lot of our partners
in emerging markets
who struggle with storage
space on users' devices.
All right, so those are
some of the highlights
of some of the
different technologies
that we've been working on over
the last few years and some
of the things yet still to come.
For the last part
of my talk, I want
to quickly run through a
couple of different case
studies of partners who
have used and adopted
some of these new technologies
and some of the results
that they've found.
The first of these that I
want to mention is Twitter.
Twitter adopted the Add to Home
Screen and PWA functionality,
and through that,
they found that they
were able to completely
reinvigorate their mobile web
experience.
They see as much as 1
million daily visits
of users who access their
application through that home
screen icon, as well as a
75% increase and a 65%--
a 75% increase in tweets
and a 65% increase
in page views/session
duration, which
is really powerful
for them and helps
unlock more value
on the mobile web.
Another interesting
application that we partnered
with more recently is Spotify.
Spotify was looking to solve
two fundamental challenges.
First of all, they wanted
to lower the friction
of accessing their application.
It's a very high ask to ask
your users to go and download
an entire application
just to listen to one song
that some friend of
yours sent you a link to.
They also wanted to
solve storage space,
because it's hard for users
who don't know about Spotify,
the application, to decide it's
worth the amount of storage
on their device to
actually go and download
the native application.
Spotify's approach was
to start small and use
rigorous A/B testing to
detect the changes in user
behavior resulting from
users who were shown the PWA
experience as opposed to being
redirected to the Play Store.
They found great results with
a 54% increase in day one
plays activations, a 14%
increase in retention,
and as much as a 30%
reactivation of users
who had churned and previously
uninstalled the app.
Next up is Starbucks.
Starbucks, similarly,
was trying to solve
two fundamental challenges.
First, they really wanted
their mobile web experience
to have full UX parity with
their native application,
and similar to Spotify,
they wanted a solution
for users who didn't
have enough storage
on their device for the
full native application.
Their approach was
to start with as many
of the performance basics
that Elizabeth did a fantastic
job of laying out in
her section of the talk,
focusing on less code,
intelligent caching, and image
optimizations, as well as
adopting many of the PWA
engaging and delightful
patterns to Add to Home Screen
and enable better sign-on
and authentication.
Their results surprised
even us and themselves.
They found that they
were able to double
the amount of the time to
interactive for their web page,
as well as a 65% increase
in Starbucks rewards
registrations, which is their
most important conversion
point.
The last case study
that I want to go over
is a really great company
that pulls together
a lot of these principles,
and that's Figma.
Figma is a powerful cloud-based
screen design platform
that makes it really easy for
teams to work and collaborate
in sync.
With native design
tools, you had
to worry about managing
the right files
and making sure that everybody's
files were up to date,
making sure that everyone had
the right software installed,
and whether or not
the operating system
that one of your
team members was
using even supported the
application in the first place.
Now by leveraging
the powers of links
as the single
source of truth, you
can easily collaborate,
ping somebody
a single string that they can
then click to instantly open up
the application, jump right
in, collaboratively edit
without having to
worry about any
of the process of installing
the application itself.
I want to briefly mention the
actual setup that Figma has,
because it's quite a well
done architecture that they
were able to come up with.
In the surrounding areas of
their application, the menus
and such, they use a TypeScript
and React-based framework,
which works really well.
And then inside of the
central editor section
of their application, they
have a single canvas tag,
where they have a custom
rendering engine written
in WebAssembly through C++ that
uses WebGL to rapidly render
that file and any changes
to that canvas area.
They also have a
custom text editor,
where they were able to take
the popular open source C++
libraries, FreeType
and HarfBuzz,
and compile those
to WebAssembly,
and then just use
those directly-- again,
one of those portability
advantages that I was talking
about earlier.
And then lastly,
they use web sockets
to enable really fast and smooth
multiplayer editing of any file
in the Figma application.
Here are some of the links
to many of the resources
that I talked about.
I will give everyone
in the audience
a second to take a
picture, or give everyone
listening and watching at home
a chance to pause the video.
This is just some of the
useful links and resources
that you have access to.
[MUSIC PLAYING]